Your doctor may perform a
transthoracic needle biopsy or bta to
diagnose diseases in or near
your lungs. The lungs are
located in the chest cavity between
the surface of the lungs and
the chest wall. There are two layers of tissue
that make up the pleura.  of the
layers the visceral pleura is
attached to the lung itself while the
other layer the parietal pleura
is attached to the chest wall
a small amount of fluid in the
pleural space which is the space between
the two layers allows the lungs
expand and contract gently with
each breath
a transthoracic needle biopsy may be ordered
to
diagnose conditions such as asthma,
lung cancer,
pneumonia, and chest injuries
before your procedure you may be
given medications to
suppress cough your doctor may  use
various imaging techniques
such as a
CT scan or ultrasound to
help you precisely locate the
target of your biopsy and guide the
insertion of the needle your
skin will be cleaned at the site
where the needle will be inserted just above
one of your ribs to help you
relax you may be given
a mild sedative and local anesthetic
to numb the area the
procedure usually takes less than 30 minutes
to begin your doctor may make a
small incision in your skin where it will be
inserted  the needle then while
you hold your breath and remain as still as
possible your doctor
will insert the needle through your skin and
chest wall you may feel
pressure and then a sudden
sharp pain when the needle reaches the
surface of your lung  your doctor
will quickly obtain the
fluid or tissue sample and remove the needle
then a chest x-ray
or other imaging techniques will be used
to make sure your
lung has not collapsed
recovery time is usually very short
you will go home the same  day of
procedure Unless there are any
complications